bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat il y a un an le groupe
communiste était à l'initiative d'une
commission d' enquête sur l'évasion
fiscale le 23 avril dernier les
sénateurs communistes ont souhaité à
nouveau débattre en séance publique de
l'efficacité des conventions fiscales
internationales pour le sénateur
communiste du nord et rim hockey il
s'agit souvent d'un double système de
non imposition conseillé par
l'ingéniosité d'avocats fiscalistes
alors ce matin retour sur cette séance
bonne matinée tous l'ordre du jour
appelle le débat sur l'efficacité des
conventions fiscales internationales à
la demande du groupe crc
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat
monsieur éric bocquet pour le groupe crc
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
notre sentiment est partagé à
l'ouverture de ce débat en séance ce
soir en effet c'est à la demande de
notre groupe que ce débat ait lieu
aussi compte tenu de l'importance du
sujet et de l'actualité très riche de
ces dernières semaines nous aurions
pensé qu'un débat aussi essentiel que
celui ci eût pu se tenir en prime time
comme on dit à une heure de grande
écoute mais l'essentiel n'est pas là
il faut bien le dire les changes aura
bien lieu ce soir nous avons vu de
nombreuses conventions fiscales passées
par notre assemblée et la question de
leur efficacité
c'est régulièrement posé avec force le
rapport récent de l' ocde sur la lutte
contre l'érosion de la base de la base
d'imposition pardon et le transfert des
bénéfices
abordant les conventions fiscales dont
l'objet est essentielle et d'éviter les
doubles impositions se révèle être en
fin de compte un système performant de
double non-imposition mettant ainsi en
évidence toute l'ingénierie et le
savoir-faire des cabinets de conseil et
autres avocats fiscalistes
ainsi donc monsieur le ministre nous
avons quelques questions à vous poser
quelques suggestions à vous formuler
quelques demandes à vous adresser le
débat qui nous réunit porte sur les
conventions internationales et leur
efficacité pour lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale
il faut partir de ce que sont les
conventions internationales c'est à dire
de leur rôle de vecteur de véhicules de
la normativité internationale en matière
de fiscalité
d'emblée cette identité leur ne le
rassure pas toutes les chances de succès
le droit international n'est pas le plus
puissant des droits fruit de compromis
il est vite et souvent mal sanctionné ce
qui évidemment peut nuire à son autorité
mais enfin ses faiblesses n'empêche pas
de le préférer aux solutions ou la force
pure ne s'embarrasse pas de prendre le
détour du droit négocié il faut en
réalité envisagé trois grandes
catégories de conventions certaines sont
bilatérales certaines autres sont
multilatérales selon l'objet de chacune
nous avons d'abord les conventions
fiscales internationales qui sont
l'équivalent dans l'ordre international
entre législation fiscale interne il ya
ensuite les conventions d'entre elles ou
d'assistance judiciaire qui forment une
sorte de mélange le code pénal et de
code de procédure pénale entre les états
qui peut évidemment trouvèrent à
s'appliquer à en matière de délits
fiscaux
et enfin nous avons un réseau
conventionnel un peu balbutiant mais
probablement appelée à jouer un rôle de
plus en plus essentielle si les états
acceptent de s'affranchir de la tutelle
les établissements de crédit qui tourne
autour de ce champ hier presque vierge
aujourd'hui à peine labouré qu'est la
lutte contre le blanchiment
chacun de ces instruments qui devrait
contribuer à un ordre fiscal juste est
très souvent un échec
les conventions fiscales internationales
au sens strict répartissent la
souveraineté fiscale ou du moins tentent
de le faire car il faut tenir compte du
comportement des contribuables n'est
plus un délicat qui s'entendent à en
déjouer la portée elle fixe
l'attribution du droit d'imposer et
prévoit les moyens de consolider le
droit de chacune des parties au traité
via des procédures de gestion
administrative de l'impôt dans ses
procédures de sécurisation du droit
l'échangé d'informations jouent un rôle
non exclusive mais essentiel ces
conventions généralement bilatérales
sont encadrés par des conventions
multilatérales qui fixe un certain
nombre de principes portant sur les deux
volets la répartition du droit d'imposer
la gestion des relations entre
administrations fiscales pour en
appliquer les dispositifs les deux
aspects de ces conventions sont bien sûr
important
la répartition du droit d'imposer engage
notre capacité à défendre la
souveraineté fiscale de la france
cette dimension de notre diplomatie
économique a fait surface pendant la
campagne des dernières présidentielles
les deux candidats qualifiés pour le
second tour avait annoncé une
renégociation plus ou moins étendu les
conventions bilatérales
le candidat finalement élu avait
souhaité renégocier quelques conventions
avec la belgique avec la suisse
notamment
où en sommes-nous monsieur le ministre
par ailleurs avez vous entrepris de
remédier aux situations de double
imposition
quel diagnostic pouvez vous nous
présenter à ce sujet mais pouvez-vous
nous présenter votre programme
négociations pour porter remède à ces
situations
enfin nous serions bien intéressé de
pouvoir disposer d'une évaluation nous
permettant d'apprécier les effets
fiscaux des régimes dérogatoires par
rapport au modèle de convention de
l'oscd e offerts à certains pays et
également de pouvoir vérifier si des
contreparties économiques de ces cadeaux
ont toujours été au rendez vous nous
permettons de suggérer monsieur ministre
de procéder à l'évaluation des
conditions dans lesquelles les intérêts
financiers publics sont défendus par
l'économie des conventions fiscales
cette évaluation devra être réalisée
convention par convention et faire
l'objet d'une synthèse permettant
d'élaborer une véritable stratégie
fiscale internationale
nous sommes demandeurs d'une
communication des résultats
sur l'autre volet la gestion
administrative de l'impôt et en
particulier du contrôle fiscal
autant le dire tout de suite nous
entrons ici dans le vif du sujet c'est à
dire dans une vaste invraisemblances qui
voit le bouclier se transformer en armes
d'auto destruction particulièrement
perfide
il faut évidemment mentionner ici le
rôle de l'eau sérieux cette organisation
des pays développés a été chargé par le
g20 le fameux g20 qui a supprimé par
décret souvenez-vous les paradis fiscaux
en 2009
chacun le sait de lutter contre les
états non coopératifs en procédant à un
examen par les pairs des conditions dans
lesquelles les pays s'applique à jouer
le jeu de la transparence fiscale dans
le processus du forum mondial
les conventions fiscales ont été
instrumentalisés pour permettre aux pays
non coopératifs échapper à ce que les
anglais appellent naming shaymin nommé
jeté la honte sur les gens tout ceci
s'est déroulé sous les auspices et avec
la bénédiction des états de l'oscd
combien de pays inscrits sur liste noire
des paradis fiscaux ont ils pu en sortir
par la simple signature de conventions
fiscales avec des états aussi peu
scrupuleux que quel a été le prix payé
aux iles féroé ou à andorre pour avoir
accepté de signer les conventions
fiscales avec les îles caïmans afin que
celle ci sortent de la liste
il faut nous le dire monsieur le
ministre et il faut que vous plaidiez à
l' ocde pour qu'au minimum il soit mis
fin à cette imposture
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire ici
même
si les listes les paradis fiscaux se
vident les listes des contribuables
disposant de cours dans ces juridictions
ne cesse d'enfler
j'y reviendrai commençons par faire le
ménage c'est nous chez nous c'est à dire
en europe et en france
combien de temps encore devrons nous
supporter de l'autriche la suisse le
luxembourg triche
combien de temps encore devront nous
tolérer que la france vite sa liste des
états non-coopératifs désarmant au
passage des trop rares et faibles
instrument anti évasion de notre
législation fiscale
monsieur le ministre combien de demandes
d'assistance administrative avait vous
adresser à vos homologues dans le monde
à qui et pour quel résultat je voudrais
vous dire notre satisfaction que la
france et tourner le dos à la tentation
de signer les accords rubik dans
lesquels la suisse entendu acheter la
paix fiscale si je puis dire
nous avons été très inquiet j'ai
personnellement été interviewé par des
journalistes helvétique avec mes
collègues de la commission d' enquête
sur place sont des rumeurs de ralliement
de la france d'après mai 2010 2012
pardon à ses sirènes ou devrais je dire
à ses cors des alpes maastricht par un
rubik ce n'est rien d'autre qu'une
amnistie fiscale
excusez le lapsus il est tard il
n'empêche que nous aimerions connaître
quelles initiatives ont été prises au
nom de la france
devant l'attitude de certains de nos
partenaires dans l'union européenne qui
pratique une duplicité tout à fait
inadmissible signant d'une main ce que
de l'autre il déchire il est de plus en
plus question d'un fac cas européen
devant ce que d'aucuns voient comme la
faillite des conventions bilatérales
pourquoi pas une piste peut être
intéressante mais ne nous leurrons pas
le fatca européen pour exister devra
être adossé à une ferme volonté
politique
il fait manifestement défaut dans cette
europe où la concurrence fiscale s'étend
à la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
par ailleurs ne soyons pas trop naïf le
fatca des états unis ne nous fera aucun
bien au demeurant que de l'appliquer
t-il au delaware ou wyoming nos amis
je vous suggère monsieur ministre de
lancer au plus vite vos services de la
direction générale du trésor sur les
effets de cette opération sur les flux
de capitaux dans le monde
ils pourront utilement s'inspirer de
l'étude de zut man et johansen sur
l'impact des conventions fiscales
je ne résiste pas à la tentation d'en
citer une des conclusions
le durcissement des conventions avec un
pays la suisse par exemple se traduit
par le déplacement des fonds non vers le
pays qui a obtenu le durcissement mais
vers d'autres contrées de l'off shore
singapour par exemple étant donné les
mesures annoncées ici ou là en europe
nous vous demandons monsieur le ministre
de faire en sorte que les flux de
capitaux entrants et sortants des pays
de l'union européenne et ses partenaires
soient surveillés et contrôlés avec la
plus extrême vigilance
moyennant quoi nous sommes évidemment
très favorable à un échange automatique
d'informations le système actuel étant
totalement inadaptés comme nous l'avait
remarquablement exposé monsieur van
ruymbeke à la mission du contrôle fiscal
l'an dernier j'en viens donc à une
question qui est particulièrement
inquiétante comme vous savez
parfaitement monsieur ministre celle des
conditions dans lesquelles les
conventions fiscales sont appliquer
concrètement lors des travaux de notre
commission d' enquête sur l'évasion
fiscale internationale
nous avons pu être alerté sur les
difficultés présentées par la mise en
oeuvre effective de conventions conclues
avec des pays qui vont jusqu'à dénoncer
les accords conclus avec la france je
relève au passage que les motifs de
certaines dénonciations sont
intéressants et pourraient être
utilement médités pour résoudre la très
intéressant problème de la légitimité du
droit d'imposer je songe en particulier
au danemark et à la question de
l'imposition des revenus différés
la question est de savoir où nous en
sommes des litiges qui nous oppose avec
nos co contractants et si en particulier
en matière de prix de transfert ou
parvenant à faire réellement prévaloir
le droit au delà me référant à
l'actualité mais n'oublions pas des
dossiers plus anciens dont nous avons pu
prendre connaissance je voudrais vous
poser quelques questions précises qui
illustre un problème de gouvernance
auxquels votre commission d' enquête
sénatoriale avait souhaité apporter une
solution en préconisant notamment comme
première mesure
la création d'un haut commissariat la
défense des intérêts financiers publics
qui aurait pu être le garant de la
transparence de ces procédures
première question monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer les raisons
pour lesquelles la convention fiscale
bilatérale entre la france et la suisse
a pu aboutir à se former de la situation
de fortune de monsieur cahuzac une
représentation si fausse que le ministre
de l'économie s'est dit entre guillemets
utilisés tandis qu'un journal d'une
incroyable complaisance a pu titrer sur
le blanchiment mot doublement malheureux
en l'occurrence concernant la personne
impliquée
nous aimerions d'ailleurs avoir quelques
précisions sur le sens de ces propos
monsieur milices car nous vous confions
ne pas être tout à fait rassuré qu'un
ministre de l'économie et des finances
avoue avoir été utilisé nous ne
percevons que trop combien les
monétaristes de tout poil les partisans
du démâté du démantèlement de l'état
social
les adeptes de la précarisation des
salariés vous utilisent pour placer la
france dans la spirale de la déflation
du chômage et de l'appauvrissement
deuxième question monsieur ministre sur
les traitements très énigmatique qu'a pu
recevoir le listing remis par monsieur
hervé falciani à la justice de notre
pays
je veux parler de la très mal nommée
liste des 3000 le rapport de leur
commission denquête comportait un
certain nombre de questions auxquelles à
ce jour nul réponse n'a été apportée
or le parcours de cette liste tels que
relatés par plusieurs acteurs de ce
dossier est particulièrement intriguant
si je peux être bref je rappellerai que
voilà une liste communiquée
administrations fiscales dont celle ci
nous dit qu'elles n'étaient en aucune
façon exploiter cet étrange puisqu'elle
laisse supposer l'existence d'un très
grand nombre de contribuables fraudeurs
finalement par l'intermédiaire du
procureur de nice qui dispose
d'informations cryptée la liste arrive
sur le bureau de l'administration
fiscale
celle ci indique avoir identifié trois
mille titulaires de comptes
mais quand même 8000 l'occurrence le
procureur s'étonne car les services
techniques qui il avait confié les
données informatiques indique qu'elle
aurait rempli un train de marchandises
même avec lui me l'occurrence c'est
plutôt une mobylette éventuellement un
triporteur à quoi on a affaire
l'administration fiscale nous dit avoir
laissé tomber la liste de l'informateur
pour privilégier seuls les procureurs le
procureur nous dit qu'il n'y retrouve
pas ses petits et suggère que quelque
chose s'est passé au niveau des services
techniques soin de lire ses gènes soit
du service de la douane judiciaire
nous avons demandé qu'une enquête
administrative soit ouverte à ce propos
l'at elle était un autre témoignage
compte beaucoup
le procureur nous indique je cite en
réalité monsieur phal ciani pour des
raisons qui m'échappent encore nous a
livré par bribes ce qu'il détenait avant
que l'autorité judiciaire n'a cherché
ces données je les suis plus tard il
semble que les tractations et eu lieu
avec les services fiscaux ce qui n'est
pas peu dans ce dossier fin de citation
ce n'est en effet pas peu avez vous
monsieur ministre fait vérifier
l'existence de telles tractations c'est
assez crucial car on peut facilement
imaginer leur objet la liste transmise
au procureur malgré son volume
n'avait-elle pas été quelque peu arrangé
telle est la question
enfin sur cette affaire nous voudrions
savoir si le fisc français a été aussi
dit lisant que son homologue britannique
dont nous le savons très bien qu'il a
récupéré beaucoup plus de recettes
fiscales que nous n'avons pu le faire ou
si nous nous situons plutôt du côté de
la grèce où ce fameux listings a conduit
à mettre en cause l'un de vos homologues
monsieur papa constantinou accusé
d'avoir en son temps tronqué la liste
hsbc
arrivé à ce stade de mon intervention je
lui dirai que quelques mots des
conventions d'entre aide judiciaire et
de leur fonctionnement dans le champ
fiscal et les conventions concernant la
lutte anti blanchiment
s'agissant de s'agissant de l'entr'aide
judiciaire les témoignages recueillis
par notre commission denquête sont très
inquiétants s'il entraide judiciaire
fonctionne parfois bien souvent aussi
très mal en particulier le royaume-uni
paraît des plus réticents à fournir la
moindre information
alors même que ce pays se prêtant à la
pointe de la lutte contre le terrorisme
international
où en est le projet d'un parc et
financier européen
j'ai compris que monsieur le président
de la république souhaitait renforcer le
bras judiciaire de la lutte contre le
blanchiment en france
nous lui suggérons détendre un peu son
horizon à cette europe de long
il est beaucoup plus urgent de rendre
transparente que le parc de vélocipèdes
de tel ou tel ministre je vous remercie
dans la suite du débat à la parole est à
madame marie-france beaufils pour le
groupe crc
pierre demoures monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la commission denquête créé l'an dernier
sur proposition du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen a eu un
retentissement certain est l'un des
effets avec quelques affaires qui ont
été ensuite révélé c'est d'avoir fait
mesurer l'ampleur du problème posé
la profondeur des pertes occasionnées
par la fraude l'évasion et
l'optimisation fiscale pour le budget
général
le montant rappelons le se chiffrent en
dizaines de milliards d'euros et
représente à peu près l'équivalent du
déficit budgétaire le journaliste de la
croix antoine peillon qui a appelé son
livre les 600 milliards d'euros qui
manquent à la france a bel et bien situé
l'enjeu dans les méandres de la finance
internationale dans cette hydre de lerne
de la spéculation
la france et l'europe laisse filer des
centaines de milliards d'euros de
ressources financières disponibles alors
même que les économies des pays de
l'union ont besoin de ces sommes pour
faire face à l'heure actuelle difficulté
la spéculation comme la fraude en étant
pour une part décisive responsable
là est clairement l'enjeu ou la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale est lancée en
grande envergure et nous connaissons
chaque année un redressement des comptes
publics et un élargissement des
capacités de financement de la dépense
publique comme de la réduction des
impôts ou bien ce ne sera pas le cas et
nous continuerons préoccupé par le taux
de chômage
inquiet de voir progresser encore les
inégalités sociales
inquiet de constater que des millions de
nos compatriotes non plus ou pas de
logement et que la part des jeunes en
échec scolaire progresse sensiblement la
découvre la découverte de l'existence
des paradis fiscaux n'est pas nouvelle
il n'a pas attendu la crise financière
de 2008 pour se manifester
avec un certain éclat un paradis fiscal
rappelons le n'est pas nécessairement le
paradis pour tous territoire tropicale
le plus inégalitaire possible comme peu
être par exemple les philippines ou une
oligarchie limitée se partagent le
pouvoir depuis de longues années
peut-être un paradis fiscal idéal pour
les ménages les plus aisés et les
entreprises les plus profitables tout en
restant un enfer pour la grande majorité
de la population
nous avons avec saint martin un exemple
intéressant de ce qu'est un paradis
fiscal
la partie française de l'île étant
devenue une collectivité territoriale ne
s'y applique plus qu'un code général des
impôts adapté entre guillemets aux
spécialités locales tout en restant
inspiré toujours entre guillemets par le
code métropolitain la première décision
de l'assemblée de saint martin quand il
s'est agi d'adapter ce code a été de
supprimer l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune
on peut douter que cet impôt est
constitué alors la première
préoccupation des résidents en 2007 le
revenu moyen des habitants de
saint-martin était inférieur à 7400
euros et 8,4 pour cent seulement des
contribuables étaient habilités à payer
une cotisation
autant dire que la décision de
l'assemblée territoriale ne concernait
qu'une infime minorité des habitants de
l'île
cet exemple tiré de notre territoire
permet de bien montrer ce qu'est la
logique du paradis fiscal faire échapper
certaines ressources rigueur de l'impôt
et faire en sorte qu'il s'agisse des
gros patrimoines de revenus aisés et de
capitaux importants
l'exemple de la suisse souvent cité pour
ce qui est du paradis fiscal par le tout
seul de ce point de vue être travailleur
frontalier en suisse
quand on réside en france peut s'avérer
une opération coûteuse au plan fiscal
eu égard aux dispositifs de retenue à la
source en général
pratiqué par les cantons suisses sur les
revenus du travail
exemple parmi d'autres la petite commune
d'ornex dans le pays de gex abrite une
population dont le revenu fiscal moyen
est supérieur à 40 mille euros annuels
elle rendement de l'impôt sur le revenu
français si établi à 4,3 pour cent
des revenus déclarés un pourcentage
inférieur à celui de la seine saint
denis
motif une bonne partie des actifs
d'ornex travail en suisse et leurs
revenus étant soumis aux règles locales
de retenue à la source se retrouvent en
général fort peu imposée en france
la convention fiscale prévoyant de
défalquer l'impôt déjà acquittée en
suisse de celui qui serait exigible au
barème français rien à voir cependant
avec le fameux forfait fiscal qui ne
profite pour sa part qu'à des revenus et
patrimoines fort élevé et dont les
règles sont bien moins dur pour les
expatriés français que pour les
frontaliers
le forfait fiscal se fondent rappelons
le sur la dépense réalisés en suisse et
pour l'entretien de sa personne et de sa
maison y compris à l'étranger par le
contribuable français
cette dépense doit constituer cette fois
la valeur locative ou le loyer de la
résidence occupée sur les territoires
des cantons suisses pratiquent encore ce
système
ce dispositif en cours de suppression
suite à plusieurs initiatives populaires
suisse permet ainsi à de riches hommes
femmes d'affaires français retraités de
disposer d'un logement très confortable
en suisse sans que le prix de celui ci
ne leur occasionne cependant une charge
trop élevé les quelques milliers de
forfaits fiscaux pratiqué en suisse
rapporté en moyenne derniers chiffres
connus 120 à 125 mille francs suisses
aux administrations cantonales
concernées chiffre sans commune mesure
évidemment avec les pertes fiscales
occasionnés aux pays d'origine
eu égard au patrimoine et aux revenus
dont disposent ces heureux bénéficiaires
je n'ai pas cité des exemples en lien
avec les plus récentes conventions
fiscales signées par la france
mépris celle actuellement en débat c'est
à dire la convention franco-suisse
pour autant compte tenu que nous avons
débattu depuis 2008 2009 d'une bonne
vingtaine de conventions dont l'attrait
critiquable convention avec le qatar
nous pourrions fort bien nous intéresse
nous interroger sur l'efficacité réelle
de ces conventions
combien de procédure d'échangé
d'informations en ont découlé pour quel
résultat
pour deux pour parvenir le moment venu à
l'essentiel la france n'a pas à suivre
agréablement nous semble-t-il les
recommandations de l' ocde et même du
gafi organismes qui en découlent
quant à la transparence financière on
peut même penser que le travail de la
nouvelle commission denquête dont nous
avons demandé la constitution mettra en
évidence le rôle complexe du secteur
financier dans ses processus d'évasions
de capitaux vers des cieux fiscaux plus
cléments
nous devons en qualité de pays majeurs
dans le concert international faire
valoir notre approche de la transparence
des mouvements financiers en nous
positionnant clairement au premier rang
de la lutte contre la fraude et la
dissimulation fiscale mettant en
question à la fois les listes
avantageusement établi deux territoires
dits coopératif et les opérateurs
financiers notamment qui continue à
exercer à y exercer des activités
nous pourrons ainsi nous demander ce que
devient la loi 2010 845 relatives à la
convention entre la france et le
gouvernement des îles caïmans ce petit
territoire où 350 personnes gère un
total de fonds équivalant au quart de ce
qui est géré à la city de londres
c'est donc à une approche critique des
conventions passées en classe
reclassement précis des pays à raison de
leur transparence réelle et à des
changements de pratiques de nos
établissements financiers que nous
appelons au terme de cette discussion le
rôle de la de l'impôt dans notre
démocratie est bien la participation de
chacun à l'intérêt général selon ses
capacités
c'est ce que nous rappelle la
constitution c'est ce qui fonde notre
volonté que cette lutte contre la fraude
fiscale
soit une priorité du gouvernement et
qu'il s'en donne les moyens
dans la suite du débat la parole est
fait par madame nathalie goulet pour le
groupe
udi us et ce président me ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances mes chers collègues quand
vous cherchez sur un moteur de recherche
conventions fiscales internationales
après quelques chroniques
après quelques revues de jurisprudence
vous tombez immédiatement sur ancien
inspecteur des impôts avocat fiscaliste
ce que je veux dire par là monsieur le
ministre c'est que dans le domaine de la
lutte contre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale c'est la guerre de l'eau bue et
du blindage c'est la guerre du gendarme
et du voleur
le voleur court plus vite et mieux
dotées mieux armées et mieux préparer
mieux conseillé le sujet du jour qui
nous est proposée par nos collègues
groupe crc fait suite à la commission d'
enquête sur laquelle nous avons
travaillé assidûment et précède le
travail que nous allons débuter bientôt
l'objet initial des conventions fiscales
vous le savez c'est prévenir la double
imposition lutter contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale un cycle blanchiment à
vous souhaite faciliter la coopération
internationale au niveau des
administrations fiscales et douanières
et évidemment organiser la coopération
entre les différents parquets d'emblée
puisque nous sommes entre nous ce sujet
n'a pas eu l'air de passionner les
foules les conventions fiscales
internationales ne sont pas les outils
les plus efficaces contre la fraude et
l'évasion pire notre réseau de
convention n'est pas cohérent et génère
parfois lui-même les outils de l'évasion
fiscale la question des deux des prix de
transfert et de ce point de vue une
caricature pour éviter la double
imposition ces conventions de vienne les
outils de l'évasion fiscale les prix de
transfert on ne s'en lasse pas on trouve
en droit interne la définition à
l'article 57 du code général des impôts
pour le cd les prix de transfert sont
les prix auxquels une entreprise
transfert des biens corporels actifs
incorporels ou rend des services à des
entreprises associées
même groupe réside dans dans des états
différents
il suppose le passage d'une frontière il
s'agit finalement d'une opérations
d'import export au sein d'un même groupe
le commerce intergroupe représenterait
d'après les estimations que nous avons
recueillies dans notre commission d'
enquête 70% du commerce international
sur la base d'une étude des économistes
pathé à novik portant sur le commerce
extérieur des états unis la perte
fiscale américaine résultant de ces
transfert serait évalué en 2001 à 53
milliards de dollars et pour la france
23 milliards points 6 soit 1.24 de notre
pipe peu ou prou le budget que nous
mendions pour notre défense nationale
qui est d'un point 5 du pimms une liste
du budget comme vous le savez je vais
vous prendre quelques exemples ce sera
sûrement plus parlant
la société suisse glencore qui est une
société minière implanté en zambie fait
perdre à ce pays pratiquement 200
millions de dollars première triche sur
évaluation des coûts de production
deuxième triche sous-évaluation des
volumes de production 3è triche
manipulation des prix de transfert le
cuivre produit est en systématiquement
vendus à la maison mère en suisse à un
prix inférieur au marché
deuxième possibilité une brasserie
implanté au ghana et qui n'a pas
évidemment 160 % de taxe d'assise à
supporter monsieur le sénateur du nord
sais de quoi je parle
dans un rapport publié en 2010 axsun
aide démonte le schéma des versements
réalisés par ses brasseries africaine
l'enquète a permis de dénoncer les
manipulations suivante donc la brasserie
qui est situé au ghana première triche
redevance en échange d'utilisation de
marque situé aux pays-bas perte a gagné
paix rhdp manque à gagner pour le ghana
250000 de la triche numéro deux
versements pour frais de gestion à une
filiale située en suisse perte pour le
ghana deux cent mille euros 3ème triche
enregistrements des services
d'approvisionnement à l'île maurice
perte pour le ghana 780 mille euros
d'autres exemples sont aussi typique de
l'inefficacité de nos conventions
internationales des rasoirs en
provenance des états unis à 113 delà des
seringue hypodermique venant de suisse à
140 dollars ça fait quand même très cher
je voudrais attirer l'attention de
certains de nos collègues nous sommes
peu nombreuses mais je vous signale
quand même qu'on trouve avec ces
méthodes des diamants naturel pour 13
dollars 45 les cas rare très franchement
c'est intéressant
quant à monsieur chavignaud qui a été
entendu par notre commission
il nous explique que les douanes
américaines ont relevé des seaux de
plastique venant de tchéquie en passant
par plusieurs paradis fiscaux à 1000 $
ce qui est quand même cher mais pour un
seau en plastique de qualité et je vous
renvoie au rapport de notre commission
denquête dans les pages 68 et suivante
est encore plus intéressant des missiles
sorti les états unis à destination
d'israël passant par plusieurs paradis
fiscaux arrive en terre promise à 50
dollars à ce prix là vous et moi on va
irions l'iran donc je ne vous parle
évidemment pas des bananes que chacun
connaît puisque là aussi les prix de
transferts font qu' il ne reste que 20 %
du montant dans le pays de production 80
% passant dans les paradis fiscaux
la cour des comptes évoque ce sujet dans
son rapport relatives à la division des
vérifications nationales et
internationales et vous comprenez bien
qu'avec de tels profits le système de
que la sous direction du contrôle fiscal
offre aux entreprises françaises étape
est un peu peu usité en effet ce service
propose aux entreprises de sécuriser
juridiquement le prix de transfert c'est
à dire de le faire agréer par notre
administration
le succès est mitigé puisqu'on a à peu
près 20 accords parents est quand même
assez peu compte tenu du nombre de prix
de transfert qui circulent en france
les contrôles sont all son compte a eu
tout à fait minime l'administration
néanmoins de bercy que le monde entier
nous envie ne restent pas
inactive la dg fipa développer des
coopérations bilatérales des conventions
de jumelage avec appel d'offres sur
l'algérie l'albanie le cameroun la
croatie le liban est important liban des
nouveaux accords de coopération sont
également conclut donc on a quand même
un travail à une tentative de
coopération et la dgfip a été élu
l'année dernière à la présidence de
l'organisation intra-européennes des
administrations fiscales ce qui est
relativement important et ce qui a
permis un certain nombre des changes et
d'information alors dans cette nuit
fiscales et dans cette inefficacité des
conventions internationales je voulais
quand même saluer les initiatives d'un
certain nombre de régions françaises et
leur volonté ont coûté 4 d'agir avec
plus de transparence
le 17 juin 2010 l'île de france a été la
première région française à prendre une
délibération contre les paradis fiscaux
suivi d'ailleurs par l'alsace la région
a voté une mesure contraignante qui
introduit une transparence avec un
'reporting' par pays est une mesure que
nous réclamons à cor et à cri re pour
les entreprises à reporter une par pays
pour les banques avec lesquelles elle
travaille se reporte in de nature à
connaître la réalité des activités est
de savoir si sa contribution fiscale est
juste au regard de la richesse qu'elle
produit monsieur le ministre vous et moi
venons de basse normandie ou de ce point
de vue là tout reste à faire nous
pourrions travailler sur notre terrain
ensemble de ce point de vue quant à
l'audition du directeur des douanes
monsieur jérôme fournel l'autre lors de
notre commission denquête il a relevé à
plusieurs reprises de points je cite
nous manquons d'outils juridiques de
prévention de lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale notre meilleure arme
reste encore une coopération qui n'est
pas toujours au rendez vous une seule
certitude la multiplication des
conventions n'y changera pas grand chose
c'est utile pour limiter les cas de
double imposition pas pour endiguer les
flux financiers colossaux mis en
évidence notamment par l'offshore lic
en revanche je crois fermement que notre
droit n'est pas encore épuisée et
monsieur le ministre je pense que nous
pourrions travailler à une direction qui
me semble faisable
important monsieur le président de la
commission des finances commençons par
balayer devant notre porte
nous pourrions à notre petite échelle
modifier notre règlement de manière à
donner davantage d'importance à l'examen
en séance publique
des conventions internationales nous les
examinons je le sais puisque je suis à
la commission des affaires étrangères
nous les examinons en procédure
simplifiée en quelques secondes sans
étude d'impact et je crois que de ce
point de vue là nous pourrions revoir
complètement le fonctionnement de
l'examen de ce type de convention de
façon systématique je crois que ce n'est
pas un très gros travail notre assemblée
a quand même un peu de temps libre si
j'en juge par l'ordre du jour chaotique
que nous avons eu la semaine dernière où
par exemple mardi nous n'avons pas du
tout siéger nous aurions pu examiner
quelques conventions internationales il
est également apparu au cours de nos
travaux qu'il fallait améliorer
évidemment la formation et les échanges
je crois que de ce point de vue là aussi
nous avons du travail à faire et que la
marge de progression est quand même
extrêmement importante et pour conclure
monsieur le ministre vous devez vous
poser trois questions
l'une de notre collègue jean claude
merceron sénateur de vendée qui m'a dit
que certaines des entreprises de sa
région ont des problèmes avec le pérou
où semble-t-il il n'y aurait pas de
convention de double imposition ou
d'évitement de double imposition
la deuxième chose a été vaguement
évoquée par madame beaufils tout à
l'heure et je le reprends je rentre
d'une mission dans les pays du golfe
je connais un peu il semblerait que la
convention fiscale qui nous lient au
qatar méteren écoles nos amis qatari
dans une meilleure situation fiscale que
la convention qui la france aux émirats
arabes unis est ce que vous pourriez de
ce point de vue là me donner quelques
explications sur la différence de
traitement de ces deux pays voisins et
amis dans nos accords j'en aurai terminé
monsieur le ministre en disant que le
sénat travaille sur ces questions que
naturellement vous nous trouverez tous
unis à vos côtés pour ce sujet important
non seulement pour
notre moral mais aussi pour améliorer le
sort de nos finances publiques en ont
bien besoin je vous en remercie dans la
suite du débat la parole est à monsieur
françois fortassin pour le groupe rda
cieux
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues ce débat demandé par
nos collègues du groupe crc et une
actualité brûlante
bien qu'il ait été demandée avant la
succession d'affaires d'évasion fiscale
qui ont ré semblable récemment ébranlé
la france et le monde
ces nouvelles offres affaires ont éclaté
avec d'autant plus de violence qu'elle
reflète en réalité un problème récurrent
très loin d'être résolue malgré des soi
disant progrès réalisés ces dernières
années celui de la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale facilité par l'existence de
juridiction règne la plus grande opacité
et où le niveau d'imposition est
extrêmement faible voire nul
comment ne pas s'interroger aujourd'hui
sur l'efficacité même sur l'utilité des
conventions fiscales qui était jusqu'à
présent l'un des principaux piliers de
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
internationale
quand le ministre français de l'économie
affirme que c'est notamment la
convention fiscale avec la suisse qui ne
lui a pas permis d'obtenir des
informations concernant une affaire
récente il faut reconnaître que la
suisse est un art si mauvaise élève en
matière d'application des conventions
fiscale prévoyant l'échangé
renseignement c'est bien dans
l'application effective des accords que
réside le véritable obstacle à la
transparence
le mot est lâché mais il ne pouvant ni
ne convainc personne
en effet ce n'est pas parce que le
nombre de conventions fiscales
bilatérales a explosé depuis quelques
années que l'efficacité de l'échangeur
renseignement est garanti on peut se
demander même si ça n'est pas le
contraire l'exemple la suisse montre
bien que la confédération helvétique n'a
jamais renoncé à son sacro-saint secret
bancaire
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu entendre
ici ou là le rapport annuel du
gouvernement portant sur le réseau
convention de la france en matière
d'échangé de renseignements souligne que
demeure un problème dans la coopération
administrative avec la suisse qui a
contesté une part importante de la
demande française
au motif le mot est très jolie même
s'ils ne s'il est difficile a expliqué
qu'elle n'était pas vraisemblablement
pertinente pour qu'on nous explique
quand même où est la pertinence en la
matière ce qui traduit de la part de la
suisse une application erronée des
standards ocde
les difficultés de l'échangé effectif de
renseignements ont malgré l'existence
convention qui sont bien réelle surtout
bien connu c'est un fait dès lors
comment renforcer l'efficacité des
échanges depuis certaines révélations
des dirigeants des plus grandes
puissances
que ce soit dans le cadre de l'union
européenne ou de cheveux qui ont tous la
même priorité
l'échangé automatique d'informations
voilà devant l'antidote tant entendu
contre les maux qui que son évasion et
les faits la fraude fiscale les états
unis ont montré le chemin avec une loi
qui leur permettra bientôt imposées
unilatéralement à tous les
établissements financiers du monde de
transmettre à l'administration
américaine toutes les données sur les
comptes mouvement de fond les revenus
des citoyens américains cette loi
combiné à la mise en place en europe de
l'union bancaire fait chanceler les pays
qui jusqu'à présent continuer au cmem
l'union européenne à s'accrocher à leur
secret bancaire le luxembourg le
liechtenstein ou encore l'autriche
et que dire de la banque du vatican
mais il semblerait que ce ne soit pas un
refuge très sûre pour gagner beaucoup
d'argent
garantir l'échangé automatique
d'informations au niveau mondial comme
semble le souhaiter le g20 si l'on en
croit les déclarations faites à
washington la semaine dernière serait
donc certainement un grand pas en avant
dans la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
et l'évasion fiscale pourtant ce ne sera
pas suffisant
en effet s'il échange automatique
d'informations parvient à être rétablie
encore faudra-t-il que l'administration
fiscale dispose des moyens suffisant
pour traiter efficacement 7 mars hélène
formation
or comme l'a souligné l'excellent
rapport de nos collègues de la
commission denquête les moyens humains
et matériels de
30 ministration fiscales doivent être
confortées en effet selon la cour des
comptes
les agents de la dgfip qui travaillent
dans les services contrôles sont
aujourd'hui sous dotées en effectifs par
rapport au service gestion
de plus elle en ce sens verifix 5 en ce
sens vérificateurs sont affectés dans
les trois directions nationales
spécialisée dans la fraude complexes et
vous international or si le premier
sacre en lutte contre l' pas citer que
symbolise les paradis fiscaux est sans
doute l'absence d'échangé d'informations
suffisantes et pertinente
un autre obstacle est tout aussi
important réside dans la capacité des
administrations fiscales en aviser
informations à réaliser les contrôles
nécessaires mais aussi à s'adapter à la
multiplicité des formes de fraudes et
aux innovations permanentes en ce
domaine
en ce sens le rapport de la commission
denquête soulignait déjà l'important se
rendre l'administration en mesure de
répondre aux nouveaux enjeux de
l'évasion fiscale le rapport fait
d'ailleurs plusieurs propositions très
intéressantes en ce sens mieux former
les contrôleurs fiscaux notamment au
regard de l'utilisation des nouvelles
technologies de l'information et de la
communication qui sont devenu le vecteur
important de la fraude ou encore créer
encore interministériel d'informaticiens
enquêteurs en mesure traiter la variété
des fraudes ou des montages de
d'optimisation fiscale enfin bien que
les récentes déclarations du g20 sur
l'échangé automatique d'informations
soient encourageantes
je crois que le passé nous invite à
faire preuve d'une plus grande plus
prudents plutôt que notre que tomber
dans un enthousiasme béat
on se souvient encore du g20 de londres
en 2009 et les déclarations tonitruantes
notre président de la république
l'époque qui affirmer pleinement
satisfait les paradis fiscaux le secret
bancaire c'est terminé on sait cette
année on nous présentait en effet à
l'époque la mise en place et fameuse
liste grise et noire de l' ocde comme
une avancée majeure dans la lutte contre
les paradis fiscaux
on sait ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
immédiatement après l'établissement de
ces listes les états ou territoires
dix langues coopératif ont pu sortir de
la liste noire dès lors qu'ils avaient
signé au moins douze conventions
fiscales prévoyant l'échangé de
renseignements respectant les standards
du modèle ocde
quoi de plus facile pour un paradis
fiscal le compte de le conclure avec ses
semblables ou avec des états qui paient
territoire du groenland où on aura bien
entendu tous les renseignements voulus
cette douzaine d'accords d'échangé de
renseignements pouvant ainsi aux yeux de
certains apparaître comme quelque chose
de tout à fait normal la liste des
paradis fiscaux plutôt d' état et
territoires non coopératifs puisque
c'est le terme officiel se sont
rapidement vidées en france chaque état
qui si aujourd'hui une convention
d'échangé de renseignements avec notre
pays sort de facto de la liste des états
et territoires non coopératifs
bien sûr il peut être théoriquement être
rétablie dès lors que l'échangé
d'information n'est pas effectif mais
combien de fois ce cas de figure de
rétablissement des paradis fiscaux sur
la liste française s'est il présenté
j'espère monsieur le ministre vous
pouvez nous donner les réponses à ce
niveau dont méfions nous des
déclarations dithyrambiques sur la fin
de l'évasion fiscale est saisissant nous
des propositions concrètes qui existent
au niveau européen pour permettre de
renforcer la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale mais aussi contre la concurrence
fiscale déloyale le serpent de mer
qu'est la révision de la directive
épargne si elle aboutit pourrait par
exemple constituer une grande avancée
tout en continuant de plaider d'être
force de proposition au niveau
international pour la transparence
fiscale
agissons dès aujourd'hui de façon de
coordonner avec nos partenaires
européens pour montrer l'exemple
le groupe rdse soutiendra le
gouvernement dans toutes les actions
concrètes pour lutter efficacement et
aux quotidiennes contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale en ce sens le seul
ministre il me semble que cela déjà
souligné que la cinquantaine
propositions issues du rapport
sénatorial de la commission d' enquête
sur l'évasion des capitaux
les actifs hors de france serait une
source d'inspiration bienvenu pour le
gouvernement
je souhaiterais qu'il ne faut pas
négliger l'homme de la rue
si on les interroge pour l'instant il ne
croit jamais à la transparence en
matière d'évasion fiscale seul peut-être
les eurocrates de bruxelles qui
convaincus de leur savoir vous ferez
croire que cette transparence existe
mais il faut dire que gravats qui comme
des notaires de province et ressemblant
à des plans de serre qui ne sont pas
forcément d'une grande efficacité car ce
qu'on a surtout besoin de chez nous de
plein vent
dans ce dans cette bataille qui sera
extrêmement rude on dans la suite du
débat la parole est à monsieur andré
gattolin europe écologie
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avant
d'entamer mon propos je voudrais tout
d'abord remercier le groupe crc en
particulier le sénateur bloqué pour
avoir demandé l'inscription à l'ordre du
jour de notre assemblée
cette discussion quant à l'efficacité et
c'est inciter ou non des conventions
fiscales internationales
il s'agit là d'un sujet qui prend un
relief tout particulier au regard de
l'actualité et il est plus que temps que
les pouvoirs publics et la
représentation nationale s'en
préoccupent sérieusement les notions que
ce débat mobilise sont en effet
structurant dans notre vision du monde
et le fonctionnement de nos états les
enjeux de fond qui s'y rattachent
concerne la solidarité au niveau des
nations et entre les nations elles-mêmes
la bonne gouvernance l'équité
internationale est là juste imposition
pas - et leur méconnaissance a
malheureusement occupé dans un passé
récent une place prépondérante dans la
marche du monde ou plutôt devrais-je
dire cette situation il n'est donc que
trop temps de nous en emparer
comme d'ailleurs le président de la
république et le gouvernement semble
aujourd'hui déterminés à le faire je ne
reviendrai pas sur la définition de ces
conventions fiscales ou sur les
politiques qui ont été mises en place
jusqu'à aujourd'hui à leur égard à leur
égard les orateurs précédents ci sont
d'ailleurs brillamment attaché mon
propos visera simplement à replacer
cette question dans un cadre un petit
peu plus large
c'est en effet une réalité largement
admise aujourd'hui le système de
conventions fiscales que nous
connaissons a quelque chose de
singulièrement absurde
lorsqu'il s'agit de lutter contre la
fraude fiscale est d'assurer un
fonctionnement harmonieux et équilibré
de l'économie et de la société
les grandes entreprises et les
particuliers les plus aisés se joue à
merveille de la division des tâches
opéré par les places financières pour
répartir au mieux leur actif et leur
passif leur activité réelle et leur
importation fictives
mieux ils ne font le plus souvent en
respectant la légalité est temps que
nous réfléchirons comme cela a été fait
jusqu'à présent
ceci ne changera pas dans cette affaire
l'europe l'union européenne s'est
montrée trop souvent éloignés et s'est
soustraite au rôle qui devait être le
sien
certains de ces états pratiquent en
effet un dumping fiscal acharnée
certains de ces territoires sont des
paradis fiscaux à part entière de même
que plusieurs de ses partenaires
commerciaux
l'île de jersey la suisse l'autriche la
city de londres
le luxembourg ou chypre nombreuses sont
ces places financières qui entretiennent
ou entretenait encore récemment pour les
unes l'opacité
pour les autres la dérégulation du
secteur financier du fait de la règle de
l'unanimité qui prévaut en matière
fiscale
l'union européenne n'a toujours pas su
se doter de règles harmonisées en la
matière
quand elles avancent comme pour le texte
sur l'assiette commune consolidée de
l'impôt sur les sociétés ou encore sur
la tva appliquée aux produits vendus sur
internet elle le fait à pas extrêmement
ralenties et parfois de manière
anachronique
faut-il rappeler ici et notamment au
sénateur marini
les effets de ces disparités sur les
libraires et autres disquaires quand ils
se trouvent concurrencée par des
entreprises opérant via internet et
répartissant leurs filiales de manière à
échapper y compris légalement à l'impôt
des soucis du même ordre pour jour quand
il s'agit de conclure des accords
multiples en matière de commerce le
bilatéral avec le canada les etats unis
le japon et dont l'un des effets sera
évidemment d'abaisser encore un peu plus
les droits de douane ceux ci sont déjà
quasi inexistant entre nos pays et ses
partenaires là entre les états unis et
l'union européenne le taux de douane
sont en moyenne de 4%
alors je pose cette question at on
besoin d'affaiblir encore les finances
de l'union européenne et en particulier
ses ressources propres
quand nul n'ignore que la puissance
publique manque cruellement de moyens
alors monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'europe a prolongé en manquer
d'ambition et de cohérence en ces
domaines
la preuve en est que des pays comme le
luxembourg où l'autriche ont sans doute
davantage évolué sous le coup de boutoir
des états unis que par solidarité avec
leurs parts
r pire la france elle-même a traîné les
pieds s'est montré très en retard sur la
réflexion autour de la lutte contre les
paradis fiscaux ou au sujet des
nouvelles formes de fiscalité nos
difficultés actuelles a parlé d'une
fiscalité du numérique digne de ce nom
témoigne de ce second point les
écologistes se félicitent donc des
annonces récentes du président de la
république qui vise notamment à établir
un échange automatique d informations
bancaires ou la mise en place d'une
comptabilité détaillé ci reconstition
circonstancié pays par pays non
seulement pour les banques mais aussi
pour les autres grandes entreprises
nous avions d'ailleurs nous même
proposer de telles mesures dans nos
amendements sur la loi bancaire qui
furent dans un premier temps partis
repousser tant la pression de certains
établissements financiers qui disait
craindre pour leur compétitivité avait
été forte
publication de la nature de l'activité
des filiales et de leurs effectifs
publication des chiffres d'affaires et
de leurs bénéfices des impôts qu'elle
paie et des subventions qu'elles
reçoivent partout dans le monde
ces dispositions sont celles sol qui
permettent de déceler et de lutter
contre les abus les incohérences et les
dérives dues à l'excès de globalisation
et de financiarisation de l'économie
surtout elle rencontre aujourd'hui un
soutien croissant le seul ocde qui a
longtemps été hostile semble en ce
moment au père et sa conversion le g20 a
le week-end passé appelé de ses voeux à
faire de l'échangé automatique
d'informations le standard international
notre ministre de l'économie qui est à
ce g20 a récemment réclamé avec
plusieurs de ses collègues européens que
la législation de l'union évolué pour se
rapprocher des politiques d nouvelle
politique américaine en la matière c'est
dire que le contexte aujourd'hui semble
porter encourageant est que nous avons
là une opportunité d'agir comme jamais
jusqu'à présent
c'est donc logiquement sur l'importance
de ne pas gâcher cette opportunité que
je conclurai mon propos monsieur le
ministre vous avez été sur ces sujets là
le soutien entier vous avez sur ce sujet
là le soutien entier résolu des
écologistes impliqué depuis de
nombreuses années dans ces questions
pour aller aussi loin que possible
nous savons que le gouvernement se veut
ambitieux en la matière nous savons
aussi que beaucoup de choses dans le
passé ont été promises et que fort peu
de concrètes ont été réalisées
nous espérons que la france se fera
aussi brillante que nécessaire au sein
des institutions européennes et
multilatérale pour faire avancer ses
préconisations
nous espérons aussi que les moyens
législatifs que vous nous proposerez les
sanctions que vous envisagerez pour les
contrevenants les propositions que vous
ferez pour révolutionner la fiscalité
française européenne et internationale
seront à la hauteur des enjeux
je vous remercie dans la suite du débat
la parole est à monsieur philippe marini
pour le groupe ump
sur le président sur le ministre mes
chers collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
vous saluer monsieur le ministre puisque
si je ne me trompe pas c'est votre
première présence en séance publique au
sénat au titre de vos nouvelles
fonctions
je voudrais aussi rendre à mon tour
hommage à l'initiative du groupe crc qui
nous a proposé l'organisation de ce
débat et ceci est particulièrement
opportun
alors qu'une nouvelle commission
denquête va et débuté ses travaux au
sein de notre assemblée
ceci doit aussi permettre je l'espère au
gouvernement de nous faire part de
l'état des discussions internationales
et en particulier du contenu du g20 de
la semaine dernière comme chacun le sait
la commission des finances s'intéresse
de près aux conventions fiscales elles
traitent au fond les projets de loi de
ratification et la tradition depuis nos
anciens collègues
adrien gouteyron et nicole bricq jusqu'à
aujourd'hui michel andré et
d'approfondir la recherche autant qu'il
est possible et afin que l'ensemble des
membres de la haute assemblée soit
éclairé sur les enlever notre commission
est bien placé pour mesurer
je voudrais et le dire en premier lieu
l'ampleur de changement de braquet de la
politique conventionnelle de la france
au cours de ces dernières années tant
pour ce qui concerne le nombre de
conventions conclues que pour ce qui est
est
du contenu et de l'ambition affichée par
ses textes et je voudrais dire que ce
changement de braquet résulte de
l'impulsion qui a été donné ces
dernières années par le président
sarkozy
je me réjouis et que cette impulsion
soient reprises par le gouvernement
actuel
en effet et à l'automne 2008 lorsque la
crise financière a éclaté
et alors que nicolas sarkozy présidait
le conseil européen
il a su et agir pour que le g20 se mette
en place soit efficace puis pour mettre
à l'ordre du jour du g20 de londres
la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
bancaire et judiciaire et c'est dans la
foulée de cette action internationale et
que le modèle de convention de l'oscd
eux qui dormait dans les cartons dans
les greniers du château de la muette
depuis des années s'est imposé comme le
standard mondial
désormais le forum mondial de l'eau c d
e
weil en principe à ce que les
engagements que les états ou territoires
ont pris et afin de sortir des listes
noires ou grises de l'organisation
veille à ce que ces engagements soient
bien suivies d'effet en conséquence la
france a depuis 2009 conclut ou réviser
ces conventions avec 28 états ou
territoires dont par exemple andorre la
suisse
nous en reparlerons le liechtenstein ou
îles de jersey et ceci afin de conformer
ses textes au modèle de l' ocde qui
interdit je le rappelle la partie
requise de s'abriter derrière le secret
bancaire pour refuser de répondre à une
demande individuelle les progrès
sont donc réels par rapport à la
situation qui prévalait avant 2009
au demeurant je me réjouis que l'actuel
gouvernement et conserver le même cap
en soumettant à la ratification du
parlement plusieurs nouvelles
conventions avec les philippines au mans
aruba
par exemple elle aussi calqué sur le
modèle ocde et maintenant je voudrais
après ce rappel et mettre l'accent sur
notre préoccupation permanente qui est
non seulement l'existence des accords
mais l'effectivité de leur mise en
oeuvre
notre commission des finances n'a jamais
fait preuve d'une naïveté béate face à
la réalité
les rapports et les débats de notre
assemblée sont là pour démontrer notre
volonté de ne pas nous contenter de mots
fusse t-il écrit dans des conventions
mais de veiller à la réalité
l'application effective des nouvelles
dispositions conventionnelles et j'en
donnerai simplement quelques exemples
lors de l'examen de la dernière loi de
finances rectificative pour 2009 au sein
de laquelle fut créé la notion d'états
ou territoires non coopératifs
j'avais défendu en qualité de rapporteur
général et avec le président jean
arthuis un amendement dont l'adoption
aurait abouti à l'inscription de la
suisse
parmi les états et territoires non
coopératifs
nos voisins oriente alors choisi de
suspendre le processus de ratification
de l'avenant à la convention
franco-suisse en raison de l' affaire
évoquée tout à l'heure et du listing hsd
c'est d'ailleurs dommage que nous
n'ayons pas été suivi à l'époque à la
fin de 2011
considérant que le panama n'avait pas la
capacité juridique de mettre en oeuvre
la convention avec la france
notre rapporteur général de l'époque
nicole bricq nous avait incité à rejeter
l'avenant provoquant ainsi ce qui est
une rareté une cmp sur une convention
fiscale nous ayons permis de siéger dans
la salle de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'assemblée nationale
puisque à l'assemblée nationale ce c'est
cette commission qui rapporte au fond et
non pas la commission des finances et
plus récemment les rapports de michel
andré je le souligne à nouveau rappel
que s'il est possible de retirer un état
de la liste des non coopératifs il est
également possible de lire m
s'il ne respecte pas ses engagements à
partir de là de cet état des lieux
commente aller plus loin que faire à
présent que nous disposons de quelques
années de recul sur les premières
conventions négocier ou renégocier à la
suite du g20 de 2009
et tandis que lé enquêtes dites offshore
l'x d'un réseau de journalistes
internationaux a bien montré que les
paradis fiscaux
demeure une réalité quotidienne
première piste que je voudrais évoquer
avec vous développer l'échangé
automatique
ce qui signerait véritablement la fin du
secret bancaire la france nous le savons
plaide depuis longtemps en faveur d'une
systématisation de l'échangé automatique
les positions du précédent gouvernement
dans le cadre de la renégociation de la
directive épargne ont été heureusement
reprise à son compte par le gouvernement
actuel
avec quatre autres états notre
gouvernement vient par ailleurs de
lancer un appel au commissaire européen
semeta chargé de la fiscalité
en vue de la mise en place en europe
d'un dispositif inspiré du fatca
américains que nous irons et analysé du
moins sur lequel nous tâcherons de nous
documenter lors du prochain déplacement
du bureau de la commission des finances
aux états unis serait utile que le
ministre nous en disent un peu plus à ce
sujet mais en tout état de cause il
semble que les choses bougent un peu
l'europe est à cet égard le conseil
européen du 22 mai pourrait être sans
doute nous le dire et vous monsieur le
ministre une étape importante
deuxième piste il convient tout
simplement de mieux utiliser les outils
existants et je ferai une allusion
légère à l'actualité récente et un
dossier bien connus très médiatisé et
qui m'a amené à m'intéresser de près au
fonctionnement concret de deux
conventions fiscales celles avec la
suisse est celle avec singapour et ceci
me servira d'exemple pour étayer mon
propos tout d'abord la convention
franco-suisse qui est symbolique à bien
des égards et dont le dernier avenant
est entrée en vigueur le 4 novembre 2010
je relève que le dernier jaune
budgétaire sur le réseau conventionnel
de la france en matière d'échangé de
renseignements annexé au projet de loi
de finances pour 2013 comprend des
passages critiques sur la qualité de
notre coopération avec la suisse
notre pays avait au 31 décembre 2011
adressée 98 demande d'assistance
administrative à la confédération
helvétique et n'avait reçu à la même
date que 55 réponse ce ton conduite à
s'interroger sur le délai de réponse des
autorités suisses mais ne donne pas
d'indication quant à la qualité des
réponses reçues il semble bien qu'un
nombre significatif de demandes soient
jugés non pertinentes par notre voisin
pourtant il est désormais bien connu
puisque on en a parlé
quelques jours que l'avenant franco
suisse était complétée ce qu avait
relevé d'ailleurs adrien gouteyron
devant notre assemblée compléter le 11
février 2010 par un échange de lettres
entre les directeurs d'administrations
fiscales permettant d'interroger les
suisses même lorsque l'on ne connaît pas
avec certitude la banque concernée et je
m'interroge toujours sur les raisons
pour lesquelles il semble bien que nous
n'utilisions pas pleinement cette
faculté
quoi qu'il en soit s'agissant de la
suisse la question qui se pose est la
suivante
sommes-nous monsieur le ministre à
l'aube d'une nouvelle ère de la
coopération franco suisse ou bien les
difficultés identifiées dans le jaune
budgétaire à l'automne dernier
subsistent tels un cas récent a permis
de montrer que les autorités suisses
pouvaient répondre de manière rapide et
constructive
un nouveau test important nous permettra
de nous faire une idée du niveau réel de
collaboration avec notre partenaire
suisse selon la presse en effet la
france a effectué des demandes
d'assistance administrative concernant
quelques 353 contribuables qui aurait
été démarché par la banque ubs
de manière plus générale il est
important me semble-t-il pour les
parlementaires qui ne peuvent participer
aux discussions entre administrations
fiscales de comprendre de mieux
comprendre difficultés concrètes
auxquelles se heurtent inévitablement la
direction générale des finances
publiques
j'ai le sentiment que certains états
limitent leur assistance à la simple
confirmation des informations obtenues
par les services français qui doivent
recueillir par eux mêmes des données
très détaillées avant de pouvoir espérer
des réponses sans verser dans la naïveté
on aurait pu penser que eu égard aux
discours public des gouvernements et à
l'intérêt de contenir l'évasion des
capitaux
les autorités des pays bénéficiaires des
mouvements contribuerait à llanelli
des mouvements suspects par exemple
lorsqu'un même établissement bancaire
procède à des transferts massifs de
comptes depuis un pays dans lequel les
règles sont sur le point de se durcir
je souhaiterais connaître votre analyse
sur ces sujets monsieur le ministre ne
pensez vous pas aussi qu'il faudrait
même si la france est déjà aux
avant-postes toujours plus stimuler
notre réseau conventionnel afin de faire
comprendre aux états requis le principe
de proportionnalité derrière lequel
s'abritent souvent pour justifier leur
peu d'empressement à diligenter des
recherches mais ce principe ne doit-il
pas aussi valoir pour la requête qui ne
peut pas toujours être d'une
extraordinaire précision en cas de refus
trop fréquents d'un partenaire qui ne
permettrait pas une application
satisfaisant de notre loi fiscale est la
conclusion d'une convention ne devrions
nous pas être en mesure de solliciter le
forum mondial pour qu'il procède à une
nouvelle investigation ne devrions nous
pas allé jusqu'à assumer
l'inscription ou la réinscription de
l'état concernés sur notre liste des
états et territoires non coopératifs
je termine par la dernière piste
renforcer le contrôle démocratique
la souveraineté fiscale de nos états est
aujourd'hui menacée on le sait plusieurs
d'entre vous l'ont dit très justement
par les pratiques à la fois illicites et
immoral d'évasion fiscale mais aussi par
la manipulation de leurs bases
d'imposition par les grandes entreprises
une bonne information des citoyens et du
parlement est essentiel à cet égard
monsieur le ministre le jaune sur les
conventions fiscales annexé au projet de
loi de finances me paraît toujours un
peu maigre il doit à minima être
enrichie de données qualitatives sur le
caractère satisfaisant ou non des
réponses adressées à la france par
chaque pays partenaire
je regrette d'autre part que l' annexe
au projet de loi de finances dans
laquelle doit être présenté un bilan
annuel des contrôles
actu et par l'administration fiscale un
ex créé par la loi de finances initiale
pour 2011 n'est toujours pas été publiés
un tel document fournirait pourtant au
parlement monsieur le ministre des
informations précieuses notamment sur
les demandes de documentation procédures
et contrôles concernant la manipulation
des prix de transfert et c'est un enjeu
essentiel sur lequel j'insiste à mon
tour il ne s'agit là évidemment de
quelques pistes en préambule des travaux
qui s'annonce très riche et que vont
conduire dans les semaines qui viennent
à nouveau nos collègues éric bocquet et
philippe dominati
je leur adresse par avance ainsi qu'à
tous ceux qui s'associeront à leurs
efforts tous les encouragements de la
commission des finances et vous remercie
de votre attention dans la suite du
débat la parole est à madame michel
andré pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en tant que
rapporteur au nom de la commission des
finances de plusieurs projets de loi
ratifiant les conventions fiscales et
des accords d'échangé de renseignements
j'ai été amené à analyser en détail ses
instruments bien évidemment je n'ai pas
ici la prétention d'en savoir autant que
nos collègues qui ont travaillé au sein
de la commission et remercie éric
bocquet d'avoir ce soir poser la
question ici dans cet hémicycle
mais je voudrais rappeler que la
politique conventionnelle française
s'inscrit dans le cadre multilatéral mis
en place par l' ocde et j'ai bien
entendu les critiques qui arrive ce soir
sur cet organisme au cd mais faut-il
rappeler ce que son directeur monsieur
de saint-amand disait à l'un de nos
collègues en commission des finances il
y a quelques jours devant sa critique
notre collègue jean germain lui ai fait
la remarque de quelque chose
satisfaisant intellectuellement sans
doute et politiquement dérangeant il
avait dit qu'il était un outil au
service des politiques et qu'il était
utile que nous nous en parlions nous les
politiques de cet outil compris pour le
réformer mais j'y reviendrai vous
permettrait donc je refasse un tout
petit peu l'historique peut-être pour
nos collègues des 2000 en effet le cd a
publié une première liste des paradis
fiscaux
rappelons les caractéristiques d'un
paradis fiscal
un état ou un territoire dans lequel les
impôts directs sont insignifiants ou
inexistants ou les activités économiques
substantielles sont rares et où il n'ya
pas de transparence sur le régime fiscal
ni de transmission de renseignements aux
administrations fiscales des autres pays
en 2002 un modèle de convention sur les
changes de renseignements en matière
fiscale avait donc été élaboré au sein
de l' ocde il s'agissait alors de
s'accorder sur des standards
internationaux en matière des changes
des renseignements afin de lutter contre
les pratiques dites dommageable ces
standards définis ils ont trouvé leur
place à l'article 26 du modèle de
convention fiscale sur le revenu et la
fortune de l'eau ces deux adoptés en
ce modèle couvrant un champ plus large
que le seul échange d'informations selon
ces accords les pays s'engagent à
échanger sur demande des informations en
matière fiscale et pays requérant doit
uniquement démontrer la pertinence
prévisible de sa demande c'est la notion
de renseignements vraisemblablement
pertinents qui vise à empêcher d état
d'aller à la pêche aux informations
et c'est un sujet que l'actualité a mis
en valeur et nous y reviendrons sans
doute
cependant il a fallu attendre le g20 de
londres en 2009 dans notre collègue
marini reprenez le référentiel pour que
la communauté internationale s'engage
véritablement à lutter contre les
pratiques fiscales dommageables en
renforçant la coopération ainsi en 2009
nous aider a publié trois listes des
juridictions en fonction de leur degré
de transparence en matière fiscale
la liste noire censée l'état n'ayant
pris aucun engagement en termes d'
échange de renseignements la liste grise
regrouper les états s'étant engagé à
signer de tels accords enfin les pays
ayant signé plus de 12 accords figurer
sur la liste blanc ce dans le cadre
national également
il suffisait un pays de signer plus de
12 accords pour ne pas ne plus être
présent sur la liste des états et
territoires non coopératifs
conscient du fait que le critère
formelle de la signature de douze
accords ne suffisait pas à rendre
effective la coopération l'oscd a prévu
des modalités de contrôle des dix
accords ainsi depuis 2010 le forum
mondial de l'eau se dit examiner
engagement à coopérer des 105 états
membres au regard des standards
internationaux cette examens conduits
par d'autres pays membres comprend deux
phases la première analyse le cadre
normatif de l'état tandis que la seconde
dresse le bilan qualitatif et
quantitatif de la mise en application
des accords il s'agit donc bien d'un
contrôle de l'effectivité de la
coopération
c'est dans ce cadre que je souhaitais
rappeler que s'inscrit la politique
conventionnelle de la france depuis 2009
la commission des finances du sénat qui
est compétente au fond pour examiner les
conventions fiscales a toujours été
attentive aux observations et
recommandations formé par les c2
notamment dans le cadre de la phase d'
analyse du système juridique du pays
ainsi après avoir constaté que le panama
de sa fusée
ne satisfaisait que trois des dix
critères de transparence définies par le
forum mondial
notre colère de marigny a fait référence
nicole bricq et à l'époque notre
rapporteur général a proposé de rejeter
cette convention fiscale entre la france
et ce pays
en outre j'ai souligné à plusieurs
reprises que la ratification ne peut
être assimilée un blanc seing dans le
cas où l'échangé de renseignements ne
serait pas effectif
l'état où le territoire concerné doit
être réintégré à la liste française des
états non coopératifs
il est primordial que le gouvernement
tienne pleinement compte de
l'effectivité de l' échange
d'informations lors de la prochaine
révision de la liste de ces états cette
expérience au sein de l'os et du ciel
demeure insuffisante nous invite à
penser que le fatalisme ne pas être de
mise dans ce domaine un engagement
politique fort et partagés au niveau
international permet d'avancer la
ratification de conventions fiscales
comprenant une clause d'échangé de
renseignements conforme aux standards
internationaux constitue donc un
préalable indispensable pour lutter
contre l'évasion
certes il convient d'aller plus loin les
listes noire grise ne se sont peu à peu
vidées de leur contenu
à mesure que les états développés leur
politique conventionnelle et c'est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs l'objet de la
critique qui a dressé à l' ocde
mais la preuve que ces listes ont
fonctionné c'est justement qu'elles sont
vides à présent les états s'engager à
coopérer
désormais et cela était prévu en 2009 il
s'agit de vérifier l'effectivité des
échanges et de veiller ainsi au respect
des conventions fiscales
je voudrais également souligner le fait
que le bilan au niveau national de
l'échangé de renseignements en matière
fiscale n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux
en 2011 l'administration fiscale
française a adressé seulement 1922
demandes de renseignements sans doute le
renforcement des moyens humains et
technologiques
l'administration fiscale comme annoncé
par le gouvernement permettra-t-il de
faire progresser le nombre et la qualité
des informations échangées
néanmoins la faiblesse de ce chiffre met
en évidence les avantages que pourrait
avoir un système automatique des changes
de renseignements pour renforcer
l'efficacité de notre politique de lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale
en plus de la poursuite des travaux
scène ocde toutes les mesures renforçant
la transparence en matière fiscale
doivent être mobile
ise il faut se féliciter des avancées
permises par le projet de loi de
séparation et de régulation des
activités bancaires actuellement en
cours d'examen par le parlement
désormais les banques devront publier
chaque année la liste de l'ensemble de
leurs filiales pays par pays pour chaque
filiale elles devront indiquer la nature
des activités le produit net bancaire
des effectifs employés le bénéfice avant
impôts les impôts acquittés et les
subventions publiques reçues
cette mesure sera également mise en
oeuvre au niveau européen grâce à ces
informations nous pourrons détecter les
transactions effectuées dans des paradis
fiscaux
ainsi une fenêtre de tir politique se
présente ce printemps à nous certains
pays jusqu'à l'heure réticent sont
aujourd'hui prêts à s'engager plus loin
dans la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
nous devons saisir l'opportunité qui
s'offre à nous pour faire davantage
contre l'évasion fiscale qui prive nos
états de recettes dont ils ont besoin
plus que jamais notre collègue marie
france beaufils il faisait allusion très
clairement je pense en particulier à
l'instauration d'un système européen
d'échangé de renseignements inspiré de
la législation américaine appelée fatca
la législation fatca entend lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale des
contribuables américains détenant des
avoirs ou percevant des revenus via des
comptes ouverts en dehors des états unis
pour cela les institutions financières
étrangères devront transmettre aux
autorités américaines les informations
sur les comptes bancaires détenus par
les contribuables américains
les banques devront également prévu une
retenue à la source de 30 % sur les
revenus des personnes dites
récalcitrantes
enfin il prévoit un report king annuel
indiquant les noms numéros
d'identification fiscaux les avoirs des
clients américains en février 2012
plusieurs pays européens dont la france
l'allemagne le royaume uni ont signé
avec les etats-unis une déclaration où
ils sont engagés à développer une
approche commune pour la mise en oeuvre
de fait cas les échanges devraient ainsi
se faire sur une base réciproque passer
par les administrations fiscales
nationales notamment afin de respecter
les obligations de protection des
données personnelles
nous ne devons pas non plus l'oublier si
les conditions de mise en oeuvre précise
de cet engagement n'ont pas encore été
arrêtées cette initiative constitue un
premier pas vers la constitution d'un
modèle commun d'échangé automatique
renseignements toutefois on tenons bien
que le modèle n'est peut-être pas
totalement appliquée au niveau européen
en effet le principe de la résidence et
non de la citoyenneté qui prévaut en
europe en matière fiscale
l'administration fiscale française ne te
donc pas s'intéresser aux revenus perçus
par les français résidant fiscalement de
rentrer au pays
pourtant la réforme américaine peut être
source d'inspiration pour l'europe et je
ne doute pas que nous trouverons à nous
en inspirer je me félicite à cet égard
de la lettre conjointe adressée à la
commission européenne par le ministre
économie et des finances pierre
moscovici avec ses homologues
britanniques allemands espagnols et
italiens et afin de mettre en place un
projet multilatéral d'échangé
automatique de renseignements inspiré de
l'initiative américaine conseil européen
du 22 mai prochain constituera une étape
importante dans la définition d'une
véritable politique européenne de lutte
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale
monsieur le ministre
pourriez vous nous indiquez le message
qu'en port porter la france lors de ce
sommet quelles démarches ont été
entreprises pour convaincre nos
partenaires de l'urgence d'agir en
matière de lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale aux niveaux international et
national nous avons su développer des
outils ils doivent être renforcés
complété en particulier au niveau de
l'union européenne
il est de notre responsabilité
gouvernement et parlement de transcrire
cette volonté politique en acte et nous
devons le faire je vous remercie de
votre attention dans la suite du débat
la parole est un monsieur philippe
dominati pour le groupe ump
ça
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ce débat
sur l'efficacité des conventions
fiscales internationales s'inscrit comme
cela a été rappelé à plusieurs reprises
dans le cadre de la réflexion
approfondie qui étaient engagés au sénat
sur l'évasion fiscale suite notamment au
rapport de notre collègue éric bocquet
nous